débuch et luxure sont maintenant entrés
dans la vie de l'or
[Musique]
feline queje fais au ciel queje
fait pour tomber amoureux d'un être dont
les sens me sont
satisfait qu'après plusieurs heures de
bien-être je suis à plat je suis CRE
et de nuit en nuit je
m'étiole j'ai pour manger et
remanger je perds un kilo par
[Musique]
soirée je crois bien qu'elle ne dort
jamais toute la nuit toutes les heures
elle frappe à mon
cœur aurais-je un jour assez d'amis pour
juguler son
appétit aurais-je un jour assez d'amis
pour apaiser ses
insomnies fait pas bon mais c'est que
fait pas bon du
tout de ne pas dormir près de sa
blonde et bien que je sois très
jaloux j'aimerais parfois qu'on me
seconde c'est ma antise tous les
soirs quand sur ma bouche elle se colle
quand je pense qu'il y a des veinards
qui ne font ça que le samedi
soir je crois bien qu'elle ne dort
jamais toutes les nuits toutes les
heures elle frappe à mon
cœur auraiis-je un jour assez d'amis
pour
juguler son
appétit auraiis-je un jour assez d'amis
pour
apaaiser les
insomnies
hein le dimanche c'est pire
encore pas question de matiner
grâce elle s'occupe de mon petit
corps jusqu'à ce que je demande
grâce le lundi je suis
exténué et sur mon bureau je
somnolle quand je pense qu'il y a des
cinglés qui pai pour voir ça au
[Musique]
ciné je crois bien qu'elle ne dort
jamais toutes les nuits
toutes les heures
elle frappe à mon
cœur auraiis-je un jour assez d'amis
pour juguler son
appétit avoir vos mine r joui il y a des
soirs j'ai bien peur que
[Musique]
oui